tu as le droit de pas être d'accord mais
par contre tu nous manques de respect
tout le temps et là stop
[Applaudissements]
de Secret Story mais juste avant il
paraît que donc Secret Story devrait
revenir c'est Castaldi qui avait donné
l'info en premier il semblerait que ça
revienne sur la plateforme Amazon Prime
et j'ai un deuxième scoot pour vous
c'est qu'ils auraient vendu également le
retour de popstar en allant sur Amazon
Prime il pourra aller plus loin que sur
TF1 et Amazon Prime à l'expérience du
direct avec le foot la Ligue 1 donc
c'est tout à fait crédible mais si c'est
pour nous mettre des espèces de teubé
demeurer dans une maison
[Rires]
franchement ouais je pense que ça peut
marcher après franchement la vérité
ouais mais toi tu vois il devrait mec il
devrait être remette dedans toi mais
après il y en a plus des comme moi tu
vois la spontanéité
et dis Benoît les meilleurs il faut All
Stars
que des mauvaises idées par contre moi
on peut pas les remettre parce qu'en
fait on te connaît on te suit sur les
réseaux donc qu'est-ce que tu veux
inventer comme ça c'est un inventé mais
c'est vrai que
d'avoir vécu et de et de voir aussi les
gens l'engouement qui avait autour de
nous à l'époque c'était un truc de fou
franchement tu on est personne tu tu
rentres bah oui c'est inconnu tu rentres
tu étais connu tu ressors c'est connu
et surtout tu vois que les gens en fait
ils regardent quoi qu'est-ce tu fais
aujourd'hui alors aujourd'hui je
travaille dans une région on est à une
maison d'hôtes avec une amie à moi qui
s'appelle la Villa Bella en Gironde
villabella d'accord voilà on fait aussi
des résidences
narcissique on reçoit des artistes ou
ils enregistre leur son voilà et j'ai
aussi clair tout ça
on a pris une maison ensemble en Gironde
que tu parles tu kiffes ouais qu'est-ce
qu'il a qui fait non mais non
sérieusement et voilà on avait une
maison d'hôtes et au final on avait reçu
un petit studio d'enregistrement et des
artistes qui viennent comme gradur Anas
et je veux plein d'autres voilà et à
côté je vais aussi un centre
d'esthétique à bord de choses je
travaille je me réveille le matin je
travaille qui s'appelle beauty and Seine
beauté soleil
je me réveille je travaille je suis je
suis ouais je suis pas très loin nous on
te kiffe
[Applaudissements]
pour toutes les personnes qui disent que
ce n'est pas un métier ce n'est bien un
d'ailleurs nous avons fait notre premier
tournage professionnel qui a été qui
était diffusé aujourd'hui sur un des
plus grands sites pornographiques
parce qu'on travaille pour une de leur
plateforme privée qui est donc en gros
voilà une des une des sociétés
adjacentes de la maison mère une vidéo
pour une vidéo qui voilà de vos débats
où il y a d'autres gens qui passent le
texte ça fait partie de nos limites et
de nos deux personnes ne passent une
technique
que vous faites dans la vie vous dites
acteurs de films X
en tout cas oui c'est notre métier c'est
un métier qui est en tous les cas
répertorié dans le code du travail et
moi pardon mais j'en peux plus
d'entendre les mots business chef
d'entreprise commerce on dirait des
patrons du CAC 40 pardon mais vous dites
où vont des contenus digitaux à nos
abonnés pardon la chauve-source que vous
vendez c'est votre cul je suis désolé
elle coûte 3 euros je trouve pardon en
fait ça me fait de la peine pour vous
poser
vos vidéos
de l'URSSAF et 3 euros c'est le
visionnage unique sur la plateforme du
du site qui diffuse le film en question
à la plate parce que vous l'avez dit ce
soir vous inquiétez pas on va faire TPMP
ça va être bien pour les vues jamais de
la vie
ce n'était pas le premier motif non non
aujourd'hui c'est facile de dire nos
enfants ne verront pas nos vidéos ils
ont 3 ans ils ont 6 ans ils ont 6 ans on
est dans le respect ou pas donc c'est
facile aujourd'hui de dire innoveront
pas les vidéos tu ne peux pas savoir si
les verrons ou pas je pense que se
lancer c'est mon choix perso je ne juge
pas soyez heureux mais se lancer dans le
X avec 8 enfants comme ça
se lancer une fois
je pense que c'est ne pas penser à eux
et c'est votre haine que vous répondez
bonjour
vous avez le droit de le faire
c'est toi l'employé ces mots-là à 20h à
20h30
qui va justement encore une fois tout un
montage en épingle sur les réseaux
sociaux
tu es pas bienveillante donc j'ai pas
envie de parler non non mais moi je suis
bien moi j'ai fait mon yoga je suis zen
je vous non tu n'es pas bienveillante et
tu le sais que tu ne l'es pas parce
qu'il faut faire la part des choses tu
as le droit de pas être d'accord mais
par contre tu nous manques de respect
tout le temps et là stop moi je te dis
stop je n'ai pas envie d'échanger avec
toi
c'est Cyril
c'est après non je répondrai pas hein
c'est pas une question de respect ou
parce qu'elle est toujours dans
l'attaque en fait et dans le dénigrement
c'est pas possible mais mais évidemment
on gagne notre vie en monétisant nos
contenus mais c'est pas un secret mais
en fait on fait ce qu'on aime et
évidemment on gagne notre vie avec on va
pas mais on va pas cracher dans la soupe
arrêtons des hypocrites déjà partout
est-ce que vous avez pas le sentiment
d'être utilisé et est-ce que vous avez
pas peur qu'à un moment vous dites bah
tiens ce site là vous proposer une
deuxième vidéo mais là il va falloir
aller plus loin que tu utilises pour
parler tous les soirs sur C8
son mari donc tout va bien
de ne plus avoir de limite c'est ça la
question si justement on a toujours les
mêmes limites c'est nous deux personnes
d'autres et tu vois d'ailleurs même on a
exigé que toutes les personnes donc
l'autre couple que tu avais à côté de
nous a quitté l'appartement et il
restait plus que les deux caméras
manquent parce qu'on ne voulait personne
dans le en fait on ne voulait personne
dans la technique quoi c'est ben non
regarde de vos enfants sur vous il a pas
changé mais bien sûr que non nos enfants
n'ont absolument pas connaissance de ça
puisque ils ne sont pas en âge de le
savoir et le jour où ils seront en âge
de le savoir
[Musique]
il y a eu un cambriolage le 27d décembre
dans la le pavillon
elle n'avait pas vu à ce moment-là que
deux tablettes avaient également été
dérobées donc quand elle porte plainte
elle ne se rend pas compte de ça puis
après elle savise que ces deux tablettes
sur lesquelles il y avait c'est vrai des
vidéos intimes des sextape d'aile voilà
ont été dérobés et le corbeau va
l'appeler un corbeau va l'appeler
quelques semaines après et lui réclame
directement 250 elle elle a dit je m'en
fous je ne paye pas et à la portée
plante c'est ce qu'il faut faire
halluciner c'est que j'ai lu sur les
réseaux sociaux des gens qui disent
c'est bien fait pour elle elle est
capable à faire des sextape alors
qu'elle est connue parce que comme le
monde à l'envers le coupable c'est la
personne qui dit vu que ces vidéos elle
a le droit de faire des vidéos intimes
c'est une mère de famille en plus il
faut la respecter et j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a l'ordre des réseaux c'est
devenu la mode et c'est devenu normal de
tout divulguer des photos des vidéos des
conversations privées ce qui est privé
et privé par rapport au cambriolage
parce que certes on lui a volé de
l'argent des billes
pourquoi il y a une taupe exactement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a un problème oui un problème c'est
mon vélo
la Brenda Brenda que j'adore tu t'es
fait voler ton vélo écouter ma petite
histoire c'était en janvier dernier
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il s'est passé
qu'un matin je pars pour emmener ma
petite fille à l'école vous avez une
petite fille mais vous avez 12 ans j'ai
27 ans bientôt ouais et un matin j'ouvre
la porte du local vélo je vois plus de
vélo j'ai pris une journée de travail je
suis allé au commissariat j'ai porté
plainte comme tout le monde quoi voilà
et la dame de la commissaire elle m'a
dit oubliez votre vélo vous le
retrouverez jamais et du coup j'ai fini
par le retrouver sur leboncoin un bon
matin tous les jours je regardais les
annonces tous les jours tous les matins
je regardais les annonces et un matin je
vois la petite annonce avec ton vélo
avec mon vélo j'ai appelé j'ai été au
commissariat où j'ai porté plainte je
suis arrivé en furie j'ai dit que bah
j'avais retrouvé mon vélo sur leboncoin
et tout il fallait qu'il me prépare une
équipe donc ils m'ont préparé une équipe
et j'ai dit j'ai donné rendez-vous à et
du coup je suis arrivée direct
avec ma meilleure amie on y va tout
déter tac juste avant que le mec il
arrive je dis appelle-les donc j'ai le
numéro du policier son 06 et du coup
elle l'a bipé il soit arrivé en furie
c'était caché genre une rue derrière ils
sont arrivés bam ils l'ont attrapé
48 heures de garde à vue et
là le problème alors quand ils l'ont
contrôlé il avait un couteau de 30 cm de
cuisine avec l'emballage ça c'est moins
drôle et je me suis fait gronder par le
policier en disant mais vous êtes pas
bien vous avez pris un risque
inconsidéré moi je suis en colère contre
vous parce que je vous aime énormément
et là franchement c'est délirant ce que
vous avez fait on peut pas cautionner ce
risque que vous avez pris la police une
autre solution et je le voulais
aujourd'hui je voulais récupérer mon
vélo là non tout de suite et quand je
veux un truc et bah j'y vais voilà c'est
tout toutes ces vermine là 11
condamnations on se condamnations et ça
vole encore des vélos il y en a marre
franchement il y en a marre donc elle a
eu raison tu as eu raison de faire de
d'appeler pour récupérer ton vélo là où
je suis pas très content c'est que la
police n'aura pas du tout laisser
galérer quand tu as dit le temps qu'il
se prépare ils auraient dû venir tout de
suite en voyant ta détermination ils
auraient dû dire Madame ne le fait pas
vous on va y aller nous on va il y a un
mec qui va venir faire croire que c'est
l'acheteur et un coffre il faut que j'ai
filmé d'ailleurs parce que mon idée de
filmer parce que c'est un menteur fini
il ment il ment il ment comme il respire
c'est un mythomane c'est un je sais pas
comment on dit là ceux qui veulent tout
le temps les vélos là mais euh
merci
les policiers demandent aussi de filmer
parce que ça servira pour la procédure
je pensais pas que ça allait fuiter à la
base je voulais garder la vidéo pour moi
et les policiers et l'envoyer à ma
famille mes amis sauf que elle a fuité
et puis voilà tu
il va prendre plus cher que tu fais tu
travailles oui ils t'ont dit quoi les
gens au taf
bravo parce que déjà je travaille dans
mon quartier je fais des pizzas dans le
quartier d'accord et il se met tout le
temps devant là où je travaille
Ikea des gens ils filment les policiers
comme ça quand ils passent en les
traitant de
enfin il les insultent enfin je vais
même fait sauter son compte Tik Tok
parce qu'il se filme avec le maire film
avec les policiers on les insultant moi
je cautionne pas ça c'est pas possible
cette meuf
a été lancée par des célébrités telles
que Kim Kardashian ou la rappeuse
cardique le brasilian but parce que en
fait il y a deux temps dans cette
opération il y a d'abord la première
temps qui est la liposuccion donc il va
être plus ou moins important pour
récupérer la graisse exactement après on
la prend la centrifuge et on la
réinjecte pourquoi vous l'avez fait vous
êtes dit j'ai envie de tenter le truc
vous l'aviez vu vous êtes vous dire la
vérité en fait je l'ai fait je venais de
commencer dans la télé-réalité et c'est
vrai que moi j'ai eu beaucoup enfin
quand je suis rentré quand j'ai commencé
j'ai eu beaucoup de de mauvais
commentaires sur Twitter parce que je la
taille 40 j'étais pas comme les autres
sites télé ça s'est bien passé pas du
tout non qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah
en fait au moment de la lupusion moi
j'avais des implants mammaires mais bien
avant et il a je crois touché ma glande
ma mère c'était juste qu'en fait avec la
je sais pas avec la canule il avait
touché ma grande mère et du coup il y
avait une hémorragie dans mon sang alors
bon ça c'était dû à la liposuccion donc
pas au palais opérations mais après j'ai
eu aussi un problème avec toi je me
retrouve avec une grosse boule plein de
cul qui qui s'est ouverte et qui je
pense que c'était une infection au final
donc j'ai appelé un ami à moi qui était
chirurgien il m'a mis sous antibiotique
et ça s'est dégonflé mais ça m'a fait
une j'ai un petit creux sur la fesse en
fait d'accord de quoi on meurt dans un
injection de graisse dans les fesses
essentiellement d'une embolie graisseuse
c'est-à-dire que si on injecte de la
graisse dans un gros vaisseau dans le
muscle et bien la graisse peut aller
dans la circulation générale
boucher le poumon et on peut en mourir
d'ailleurs il faut savoir que cette
intervention est interdite en Angleterre
et moi je trouve que cette intervention
elle est extrêmement risquée les Anglais
ils seront pas plus bêtes que nous et
s'ils l'ont interdit c'est que
réellement le danger existe le nombre de
gens que vous devez voir arriver peut
avec justement en disant est-ce que je
peux être comme ça avec une photo
filtrée comme ça c'est ça qui a changé
Tik Tok c'est un drame ça donne surtout
aux jeunes une fausse idée de
l'apparence de la beauté de la séduction
et c'est vraiment malheureux ça
n'existait pas il y a 20 ans vous
regrettez aujourd'hui
quand même je regrette franchement
j'aurais dû arrêter je regrette parce
que au final j'ai pas réfléchi et je
m'en vais un peu plus à moi quand même
parce que je suis majeur je suis vacciné
au final j'aurais dû réfléchir et me
dire bon bah j'en avais pas forcément
besoin en plus pour vous dire la vérité
donc j'aurais dû réfléchir et me dire
bon bah ça sert à rien de le faire juste
pour ressembler à toutes les autres
transformer l'Assemblée nationale en
congitant et c'est pas les
Saintes-Maries-de-la-Mer tu peux être
que blessé tu as entendu les promos les
propos c'est une expression tout ça
que je fasse erreur moi c'est possible
pas lui tu comprends son métier c'est de
parler mon frère il fait que ça on est
victime du racisme à mort je sais ça
veut dire que je peux pas je pense qu'on
est une des communautés les plus
victimes du racisme en France des forba
pour travailler ici ils apprennent qu'on
est gitans ils arrêtent eux c'est un
truc je comprends c'est un truc de fou
quand j'y étant ça veut dire que c'est
un peu pour moi c'est genre c'est le
Brouard ça parle fort tous les sens
c'est à quand j'y pense pas dire fuck
les gitans quand j'y pense c'est pas le
salon du rangement
tu te rends pas compte de ce que tu dis
bonjour ça veut dire que les gens
s'imaginent après c'est-à-dire dès
qu'ils vont être chez moi oui mais toi
j'ai pas dit sans le vouloir tu viens de
faire l'Allemagne La Malga aussi ça veut
dire que tu vois un truc dérangé oh mais
ça s'agit en haut de ça on dirait un
petit manouche bon moi de toute façon je
je suis par principe contre toute forme
de stigmatisation de de racisme
d'essentialisation des gens
l'accès ou pas lorsque est-ce que c'est
différent
là pourquoi parce que ça touche à toi
une chose est de s'attaquer à un
individu d'accord de l'animaliser la
c'est du racisme d'accord
il s'est excusé Hervé Marseille est-ce
que vous acceptez ces excuses dans la
mesure où tu es sincèrement voilà bien
sûr qu'on accepte les excuses mais moi
je peux pas parler
toi déjà moi j'accepte maintenant ma
communauté je sais pas
ce que je veux plus que ça arrive c'est
que ces gens là ils banalisent ils
banalise qu'on vit c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui il faut savoir qu'on vit
vraiment une époque pour nous et c'est
de plus en plus dur avec le reportage
enquêté exclusif qui banalise cette
haine après le voyage je veux plus qu'on
puisse pouvoir dire ce qu'on veut sur
nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]